[Music]
now that ugly sonic has been banished to
another franchise anyway now my luck has
shifted a surprisingly not terrible
video game movie gets a surprisingly not
terrible sequel which by sonic standards
makes it the goddang mona lisa
these fans have just been through so
so much
sonic 2
after sonic 1 hooked audiences with a
nice family film sonic 2 pops the blue
pill and shows them just how weird this
franchise gets where a zoo's worth of
animals team up to fight an egg-shaped
mech powered by a gem that makes your
dreams come true but it never strays
from one relatable easy to follow
message everyone is painfully crushingly
alone
chantral to d4
growing up i didn't have any friends i
lost everything because of you we both
lost everything that day buddies wingmen
a squad well sonic doesn't have anything
like that
doctor
where are you
fun
welcome back all your faves from sonic 1
like tom a guy trying to decide if the
thing he keeps in his attic is more like
his son friend or dog robotnik an elon
musk tight in that he's bald his tech
keeps exploding and his power comes from
stolen emeralds as jim carrey has so
much fun on camera he'll retire from
acting forever i have enough
i've done enough i am enough that's not
how celebrity works you need our love to
love yourself now get in that fat suit
we're doing sonic 3. and while jim
maintains his lock on cinema's greenest
meanies the voice of sonic ben schwartz
continues his dominance of the color
blue
i think we all know where this is going
water again
come on
party with the sonic you know and love a
mascot from 30 years ago spouting the
pop culture references of 15 years ago
who is clifford the big red rage monster
but before an extended uptown funk dance
sequence makes you check the year on
your calendar they'll introduce new
characters like tails a fox who can fly
with his ass it's cuter than it sounds
and knuckles the second best mean little
red cartoon who wears boxing gloves all
the time
gnarly he's a character that eater's
elba promised us would not sound sexy
but we'll be the judge of that sir never
underestimate a sonic fan's ability to
get turned on by cartoons watch sonic
and knuckles collide like that awkward
stack of cartridges it took to play as
him and if you don't think they'll
figure out their differences and work
together by the end get ready to be
blown away by sonic 2 because this is
probably your first movie and hey
welcome to movies they're great try some
popcorn
blast off into the sonic verse which
takes place in what appears to be a
hawaiian wedding this is still sonic 2
okay
blast off into the sonic burst to meet
rachel and randall two lovebirds who
thought their hawaiian wedding would be
a passport to paradise but when tom
crashes the party it'll be a one-way
trip to oopsville whether he's trying to
hang with the boys
misplacing the wedding ring i think i
mixed up the rings when i was teasing
jojo or disrupting the ceremony so help
me thomas you'll be saying i do to the
best tyler perry movie hidden inside a
video game project till they finally put
medea in smash bros
sonic 2 rivals down the aisle
wait what this part is still going
you remember sonic 2 rivals down the
aisle well there's still more wedding
stuff because this couple's relationship
was a sham and everyone there was
secretly a space cop or something now
this bridezilla is out to get her man
one way or another and with the help of
her maid of honor these two are cranking
up the hawaiian heat in
sonic 2 rivals down the aisle to
chaos altar all right are we done here
can we please go back to the sonic board
now
enjoy deep cut references like a
rendition of the original drowning music
recreations of the game logos
a call out to an obscure old puzzle game
and after they managed to fit the best
sonic meme into the first one i'm like
90 sure they snuck the other sonic meme
into this one i'd be happy to show you
the way
uh that's a ugandan knuckles reference
right oh boy you're playing with fire
there jim don't look that up
so get ready to cheer for a blue coat of
paint on one of the all-time classic
hero's journeys a young man with an
awesome step dad who attracts some new
followers discovers he can walk on water
gets hunted down by the government and
sacrifices himself to save humanity
which is probably just a coincidence
unless you were also jewish gotta go
fast
just as foretold our golden god is
returned
starring
i see your schwartz is as blue as mine
goku
sonic is not too fast i would catch him
cycles marsden needs moms sham weddings
and your funeral
impeccable beard work just so sharp you
must be the monopoly guy
pacific gym
and chris pratt probably
speed two
lose control
i am not watching snow dogs again that
movie is the worst
wait is sonic a park and rex fan or did
he just come up with gene ralphio's the
worst bit all on his own
[Music]
it's morbid time
let me tell you the story of the space
viking though odinson
back in my day we used to eat play-doh
for sport
now you know and knowing is half the
tacos
you're a pistol you're really funny
you're really funny